es sind nachrichten die hoffnung machen
mehrere quellen berichten dass die
russische armee ihre truppen aus kiew
zurückziehen was das für den krieg in
der ukraine bedeutet wie es dazu
gekommen ist und über alle hintergründe
spreche ich jetzt mit unserem bild
experten bei mir im studio ist
chefreporter peter tiede und unser
russische bild moderator maxime coni
kopf der übrigens stellvertretender
chefredakteur von echo moskwy war ein
oppositioneller radiosender der aufgrund
der zensuren von putin schließen musste
uns zugeschaltet sind außerdem bild vize
paul ronzheimer direkt aus kiew und bild
meinungs- chef philippe piatti auf der
aus lembeck aus der ukraine berichtet
und wir wollen direkt einmal schauen zu
dir paul nach kiew was kannst du uns
neues von vor ort berichten
shakira will man hört dass die
russischen truppen abziehen wollen oder
zumindest teilweise das bereits auch tun
dann bedeutet das auf keinen fall dass
ihr plötzlich die kämpfe aufgehört
hätten ganz im gegenteil wir haben auch
heute wieder sirenen gehört wir haben
gerade artillerie gehört wir wissen dass
die kämpfe in irgendein und butscher
immer noch teilweise weitergehen also es
nicht so dass die russische armee jetzt
einfach kehrt macht und in eine andere
richtung fährt nein das wird wenn es
denn so kommt wie die russische armee
sagt ein langsamer prozess sein in kiew
wurden diese meldungen
interessanterweise aus istanbul geteilt
aufgenommen ist es nicht nur so dass
hier große freude herrscht erst einmal
wird viel über die rhetorik der
russischen armee gesprochen die er sagt
man wolle sich jetzt konzentrieren auf
den dom was da sagt man hier na ja es
liegt einfach daran dass unser
widerstand so groß war dass wir die f
und andere teile hier so gut verteidigen
konnten und dann eine zweite debatte
über die wir sicherlich auch heute noch
sprechen werden ist die frage der
zugeständnisse denn michael dzillack der
berater von seeländischen relativ
deutlich gemacht zu was man bereit ist
unter anderem 15 jahre nicht mehr über
die krim zu sprechen ist wurde
angedeutet dass man auch die gebiete das
war nicht so ganz klar du kannst das ist
da eine mögliche einigung geben könnte
und da sagen zu mir viele ukrainer sie
verstehen nicht ganz die strategie denn
für viele bedeutet dass ein teil und zug
einen vorübergehenden rückzug russlands
deshalb weil man momentan relativ
schwach ist im vergleich zu dem was man
dachte wie stark die armee ist und dass
das dann bedeuten könnte dass die
russische armee einfach zurückzieht und
sich dann wieder stark machen um erneut
anzugreifen das ist die sorge die viele
menschen hier haben die pauldirekt die
frage rein also kann man der russischen
seite überhaupt traut man hat ganz viel
von denen gehört und wenn man sich jetzt
auf den don bosco konzentrieren will
kann das ja auch einfach nur überhaupt
nur bedeuten dass man zwischenzeitlich
sich konzentrieren will auf den landweg
auf den kompletten landweg zur krim und
dann wieder zurück kommt oder wie sieht
man das in kiew
das ist das wahrscheinlichste peter also
keiner glaubt dass man sagt okay kiew
das geben wir jetzt auf und wir gehen
nur noch in den dom bass sondern man
spricht hier so ein bisschen über das
tschetschenien szenario was war da
passiert 1994 gab es den ersten krieg in
tschetschenien von russische armee den
konnte man nicht gewinnen und wenige
jahre später 98/99 ging es dann weiter
und da hat man einfach eine
umgruppierung vorgenommen und das ist
die ganz ganz große sorge hier in kiew
also dass man zugeständnisse machen
könnte dass man etwas unterschreibt dass
es dann tatsächlich in irgendeiner form
eine lösung gibt nach wahrscheinlich
heftigen kämpfen immer noch im osten
mussten dass dann die russische armee
zurück kommt mit einer neuen strategie
denn eins muss man feststellen und ich
glaube das ist dann definitiv jetzt auch
auf dem papier klar die strategie hier
anzugreifen die zumindest kiew
anzugreifen die ist komplett fehl
geschlagen die soldaten war nicht
erfahren genug das material reichte
nicht und insgesamt hatte man nicht mit
diesem widerstand hier insbesondere rund
um die hauptstadt gerechnet der könig
auf meine nächste frage geht an sie sie
sind eben er stellvertretender
chefredakteur der oppositionellen eines
oppositionellen radiosenders in kiew
gewesen bzw sind es immer noch aber der
musste eben jetzt gerade einstellen
aufgrund der sanktionen beziehungsweise
aufgrund der zensur entschuldigung von
putin wie haben sie die nachrichten
aufgenommen
da haben wir gerade probleme mit der
übersetzung da kommen wir gleich noch
mal zu ihm zurück dann würde ich jetzt
erst einmal meine nächste frage an
philipp otto stender ja auch aus der
ukraine berichtet aus lemberg philipp
wie ist die situation bei dir vor ort
ja die situation in lemberg ist relativ
ruhig ironischerweise projekte auf die
ankündigung der russen sich aus china
zurückzuziehen erstmal einen luftalarm
in lembeck ganz im westen des landes
eine gewisse ironie also aber auch hier
glauben die menschen natürlich nicht
dass jetzt frieden einkehrt nur weil es
eine neue strategische vorgaben kommen
aber ganz wichtig ist natürlich das
symbol dass russland tatsächlich truppen
verlagert aus das heißt dass die ukraine
ist geschafft haben die hauptstadt zu
halten all das was man vor einem monat
gar nicht für möglich gehalten hat und
das ist natürlich eine sehr starke leere
denn dieses mantra dass es keine
militärische lösung gibt es ist falsch
die schlacht um hier hatte eine
militärische lösung und zwar den
ukrainischen sieg zumindest einen
etappensieg das ist die einzige sprache
die putin versteht zerstörte panzer
zerstörte abgeschossene flugzeuge und
nur deshalb ziehen die russen ab nicht
gegen irgendwelche strategischen
zugeständnisse wegen irgendwelcher
friedens handlung sondern nur weil sie
militärisch nicht weiter haben philipp
du stehst jetzt nicht nur in lemberg
sondern du beobachtest für uns auch
immer auch die auch die russische presse
auch das russische fernsehen kannst du
einmal kurz beschreiben wie das in
moskau wie das von moskau verkauft
worden ist
ja das wird verkauft als
weiser schritt in richtung frieden und
das wird als strategie na ja ich würde
gar nicht sagen strategiewechsel
verkauft wenn man behauptet ja dass man
an einem plan festhält der bislang
perfekt aufgegangen sei deswegen man
tritt einfach in eine nächste phase 1 so
als wäre es tatsächlich geben dieser
eine plan den mann verfolgt aber es wird
schwierig das wird wirklich schwierig
denn in den vergangenen wochen haben die
russischen propagandisten immer wieder
gesagt es darf keine kompromisse geben
nicht mit selensky den putin ja selbst
auch als nazi und drogenabhängigen
bezeichnet dass man kann sich mit diesem
menschen also gar nicht an einen tisch
setzen und zweitens hieß es immer wieder
wenn man es nicht schafft hier ein zu
nehmen dann wie will man es dann mit der
nato also es wird wieder ein grundstück
das die russische propaganda verbringen
werden muss im russischen fernsehen und
wie das ablaufen wird kann ich
wahrscheinlich heute abend oder morgen
bricht ja jetzt sind wir beide ja groß
geworden mit als ich mit der
sowjetischen mit der russischen
propaganda aber wie verkauft man so
etwas denn jetzt in moskau also kann
wladimir putin jetzt wenn wir die man
beim wort nehmen würden jetzt die russen
das ist tatsächlich ein echter rückzug
wäre könnte wladimir putin mit dem
jetzigen ergebnis des krieges nach hause
kommen oder die soldaten einfach
abziehen
nein das kann er auf gar keinen fall das
kann er sich nicht leisten
das einzige ziel seiner operation dass
man dann erreicht hätte wäre die
sogenannte demilitarisierung und auch
das nur wenn man sagt man habe viele
ukrainische militärische infrastruktur
zerstört aber die ukraine wird jetzt
nicht demilitarisiert sondern wird
gerade komplett militarisiert unter
anderem vom besten das heißt jetzt wäre
überhaupt kein ziel dieses krieges
erreicht so wäre es eine blamage putin
man muss sich zumindest den john bass
holen meine frage an paul paul wie ist
denn die situation ringsum mario von
mario pohl galt ja als wirklich erstes
etappenziel in diesem krieg nach dem abi
wollte 20 40 und den landweg zur zur
krim haben die lage da ist jetzt etwas
unübersichtlich sei die stadt ist opfer
schwerster kriegsverbrechen geworden sie
ist im erdboden weitgehend gleich
gemacht worden aber immer noch nicht
komplett eingenommen wie sieht man aus
sicht der ukraine jetzt die lage dort
und was befürchtet man wenn dieser so
genannte truppenrückzug jetzt in den don
was kommt das befürchtet man da
der widerstand dort in mario pohl ist
wirklich unglaublich peter also ich habe
bereits vor zehn tagen war es mit einem
präsidentenberater gesprochen der damals
meinte ja heute oder morgen droht mario
pohl zu fallen also eigentlich hatte man
hier in kiew jeden tag damit gerechnet
und man fasst es kaum dass der
ukrainische soldaten ist immer noch
schaffen zumindest einen teil dieser
stadt zu verteidigen und es gab ja auch
den anruf des präsidenten seien es
gebühren im hintergrund hier erneut dass
dieser krieg auch hier weitergeht ich
weiß nicht ob ihr es gehört habt aber
denn sie hat diesen soldaten gesagt ihr
könnt eure waffen niederlegen geht raus
gibt auf und die soldaten haben gesagt
nein wir machen weiter und um über
diesen friedensprozess zu sprechen mario
pohl ist da durchaus eine sehr
emotionale angelegenheit peter also man
stelle sich vor russland würde jetzt
tatsächlich in den nächsten tagen mario
pohl einnehmen es gebe dann irgendwelche
verhandlungen in den nächsten wochen
oder darüber und über den don was das
ganze wird sich ja ziehen das ganze dass
man sagt man zitiert aus kiel soll ja
eine
vertrauensbildende maßnahme seien der
russen richtung ukraine dass man
ernsthaft verhandeln will aber wenn es
dazu käme dann würden sich natürlich
viele familien viele menschen die dort
mario pohl verteidigt haben die
überlebenden und auch die verwandten die
familienangehörigen derjenigen die dort
gestorben sind verraten fühlen und das
ist die ganz ganz große problematik für
den ukrainischen präsidenten dass das
ganze nicht als verrat aufgefasst wird
und ich beschäftige mich jetzt durchaus
auch schon ein paar jahre mit der
ukrainischen politik ich gehe davon aus
dass wenn es irgendwo eine art deal gebe
der umstrittenen wäre dass es dann ganz
sicher politische kräfte gibt hier in
kiew die versuchen dann wenn es diese
möglichkeit gibt gegen seelands die
stimmung zu machen und dann droht so ein
bisschen hier diese widerstands welle
diese solidarität miteinander auch zu
zerbrechen zwischen denjenigen die sagen
wir müssen jetzt eine lösung schaffen
und denjenigen die sagen nein wir müssen
uns verteidigen ein guter freund von mir
mit dem ich hier unterwegs bin der sagte
zu mir als er diese nachrichten gelesen
hat um gottes willen was machen wir denn
jetzt da also die werden uns doch in ein
paar monaten oder ein paar jahren wieder
angreifen warum schlagen wir jetzt sie
nicht komplett aus unserem land mit den
westlichen waffen die wir haben das
macht doch alles keinen sinn also da
wird es noch heftige debatten geben um
diese fragen und wir mal unseren
moskauer kollegen bitte dazu zurück in
die runde was ist denn ihrer was ist
ihrer meinung nach von dem russischen
versprechen oder von der ankündigung des
rückzugs zu halten kann man dem trauen
[Musik]
dieser vertrauen dass es nicht unbedingt
das wort oder das thema oder das was man
von der russischen führung erwarten wenn
sie sich jene können die ersten
publikation die veröffentlicht worden
auf welcher welche militäreinheiten sich
um ukraine herum wäre sich vermieter wir
erinnern uns in labors hat gesagt dass
es willkommener quatsch der die
pressesprecherin hat auch immer wieder
gesagt niemand will irgendjemand
angreifen und er hat auch gesagt dass
russland noch nie ein thema angegriffen
hat und deswegen glaube ich dass alle
behaupten die jetzt losgelassen werden
muss man mit eine gewisse skepsis ritter
in der betrachten unsere gesprächsrunde
heinrich book er ist vizepräsident der
christlich-demokratischen internationale
und war von 1980 bis 2019 mitglied des
europäischen parlaments und von 1999 bis
2007 sowie von 2012 bis 2017
vorsitzender des ausschusses für
auswärtige angelegenheiten hallo herr
brok vielleicht können sie noch einmal
schildern wie sind die nachrichten heute
bei ihnen angekommen
dass angeblich ein strategiewechsel
russlands vorhanden ist gerade wohl
tonprobleme und hören sie nicht das
versuchen wir mal einmal zu regeln und
kommen dann gleich nochmal einmal wieder
zu ihnen dann würde ich die nächste
frage tatsächlich an wir hören doch dann
lassen wir ihnen noch einmal anfang
entschuldigung und sie mich ja jetzt
also der strategiewechsel der jetzt
angedeutet wird es von seiten russlands
halte ich für eine taktische maßnahme
auch nicht an wirkliche strategie links
russland ist mit der bisherigen
vorgehensweise nicht klargekommen es
sollten sich erhebliche verluste an oder
sind erhebliche verluste die ukraine
während sich sehr stark und aus diesem
grunde heraus geht man jetzt wieder auf
die angedachten ziel und uns angedachte
ziel der russen an auf den osten zu
gehen um die donbass region komplett
euro vorzunehmen um die gesamte dombach
region zu haben als auch die
landverbindung zu können aber ich halte
es nun für ein zwischenschritt und zwar
deswegen weil ich
glaube zu wissen was putin sagt in
seiner rede vor vier wochen hatte das
gericht in einem see im letzten sommer
das deutlich gesagt sein ziel ist die
stadt die blätter ukraine zu zerstören
und dich und deswegen ist das auch
gegenüber seinem volk
aufgegeben was er hat herr produkte sind
nicht nur auf diese region geht und band
verbindung herstellt dann ist er nicht
da was er als ein erfolg darstellen kann
und es entspricht auch nicht an der
motivation seinem willen des alpes
zahlreich wieder zu errichten all das
was mich nicht staatlichkeit der ukraine
zu tun hat und so weiter und das dem
unterhalt ist ein taktisches zwischen
stil wird das dann ein bisschen
entlastung für kiew und für das er jedem
mag aber keine dauerhafte lösung
ich würde hoffen dass -unfall schläge
aber ich fürchte dass die richtige
analyse wenn man putin ernst nimmt sieht
was
sie war jahrzehntelang chef
außenpolitiker des europäischen
parlamentes und haben ja auch sowohl mit
den amerikanern als auch wirklich mit
den russen viel verhandelt ist noch
irgendetwas zu erkennen von der alten
russischen außenpolitik sehen sie noch
einmal an vertrauen das man dem noch
gegenüber bringen kann
nein das vertrauen die sich nicht
dagegen oder alten sowjetunion ist ein
großer unterschied fahren das waren
konnte die wir herrn der status quo ist
so ein deutschen lassen erhalten wollen
aber udine sein region ist das hat sich
angedeutet
verschiedene male spätestens in georgien
und dass wir in systematisch
weiterfahren gesetzt ich glaube wir sind
in weiten bereichen zu blauäugig gewesen
und das aus diesem grunde von putin wie
man anfang der nullerjahre gesehen hatte
der vielleicht auch den ökonomischen
angefahren wird der anerkannt werde
möchte halt dieses ist nichts übrig
geblieben weil er sich selbst verändert
hat aber auch gesehen hat das sind dann
irgendwann anschluss nicht gefunden hat
russland hat nämlich in diesen letzten
20 25 jahren nicht ökonomisch
modernisiert und verbessert ist die alte
wirtschaftsstruktur der alten
sowjetunion und weil er jetzt nicht
mithalten kann den bürgern nicht
anbieten kann setzt er auf die alten
nationalistischen träume verbunden auch
mit der angst das ist eine erfolgreiche
open
eine katastrophe für ihn wäre für seine
politik als dank ein grund für das
buchungssystem wenn man dem also
überhaupt nicht mehr trauen kann wenn
man auch diese ankündigung jetzt nicht
trauen kann herr brok was muss man dem
jetzt entgegen setzen nicht nur als
reine sondern vor allem als geeinter
westen
seine ziele grüne hinaus
ist alle wusste was man hier aber was
wissen wir dagegen tun was müssen wir
kommt also liegt an uns jetzt sagen und
und er will darüber hinaus gehen nehmen
einfluss so und das ist das aldi gebiet
das er nach 45 gehabt hat das heißt in
mineralisierungen polens und anderen
ländern dann ist es an der deutschen
grenze da als dies die ziele sind und er
das macht was er sagt das müssen wir
endlich begreifen ist es so dass mit der
übernahme der ukraine ist es nicht
beendet wäre deswegen müssen wir jetzt
dabei helfen das ist ja die ukraine
nicht überlegen kann und aus diesem
grunde belichter auffassung dass bei
allen rechnereien hin und her die vollen
möglichkeiten einnehmen sollten gegen
russland beispielsweise dass wir jetzt
schon einen
stopp machen gas- und öllieferungen aus
russland zum selber für eine gewisse
zeit weg tun sollte wir befinden uns in
einer vorstufe eines krieges und hier
müssen wir jetzt glaube ich der ukraine
baut er wusste anschaulich machen dass
wir die lage ernst nehmen wenn wir drei
spiels weise wie wir bisher mit den
sanktionen gewesen sind in den letzten
vier wochen das schon im dezember oder
januar deutlich gegenüber publikum
gemacht hätten wenn man zu recht im
krieg vermeiden können jetzt sollte man
nicht wieder sagen das machen wir es in
zwei jahren darüber lacht und ich glaube
und soll diensten anlass nehmen die
zahlstellen wurde dass man hier ein
schritt
zurück zu dir es gibt jetzt ein szenario
anfang april werden in russland
wehrdienstleistende gezogen und diese
wehrdienstleistenden so heißt es könnten
zusammen mit mit vertrags mit vertrags
reservistin in russland die standorte
übernehmen und die kaserne in betracht
da haben wir einmal pro knochen die
kasernen betreiben und dann könnten noch
mehr berufssoldaten als bisher mit
modernen waffen kommen auch mit der
luftwaffe was hält man von diesem
szenario in kiew
ja ich glaube das sind szenarien auf die
man sich definitiv vorbereiten muss
peter ich glaube allerdings dass man
hier in dem krieg bislang gemerkt hat
dass jetzt im soldaten die sozusagen
frisch rekrutiert werden und dann hier
so muss man es ja sagen als
kanonenfutter eingesetzt werden nicht
wirklich weiter helfen also man braucht
definitiv wenn man hier weiter
erfolgreich sein will einen größeren
umfang an berufssoldaten auch an
spezialkräften wir haben gehört dass
wagner soldaten der freiwilligenarmee
die hoch ausgerüstet und natürlich hoch
erfahren sind bereits in der ukraine
sein sollen das sind truppen arten die
man wahrscheinlich bräuchte ich zweifle
allerdings daran das werden wir jetzt
sozusagen betrachten dass die truppen
momentan sich tatsächlich wie auch
amerikanische quellen bestätigen so ein
bisschen aus kiew zurückziehen dass das
ein schnelles szenario gebe hierher
zurückzukehren ich nehme dann wenn wir
den glauben schenken dürfen tatsächlich
an das ist ein kampf um den dom bass
weitergeben wird um mario pohl geben
wird möglicherweise das ist auch eine
große frage um odessa also die frage ist
sozusagen wie groß definiert russland
den don bars und was das dann bei
verhandlungen bedeutet die ukraine wird
darauf pochen dass bei allen
verhandlungen ist sozusagen eine
akzeptanz nur für den teil geben kann
den es vor dem 23 februar bereits
gegeben hat in dem acht jahre dauernden
krieg also rundum donetsk und um lugansk
das wird eine hoch komplizierte
angelegenheit sein denn russland
wiederum definiert den don was viel
weiter und definiert da auch ukrainische
staatsgebiete alles ist ukrainische
staatsgebiet aber sozusagen nicht
besetztes staatsgebiet mit ein also das
sind hochkomplexe fragen allerdings muss
man sagen gehe ich nicht davon aus dass
man sich aus russischer perspektive
ich sage mal in den nächsten wochen
traut erneut eine großoffensive hier auf
kiew zu unternehmen denn man hat gesehen
wie groß der widerstand ist man weiß
auch dass noch mehr waffen hier
reingekommen sind und das macht den
großen unterschied zu mario pohl zu
cerny von anderen regionen die
bombardiert werden das flug und das
flugabwehrsystem und das
raketenabwehrsystem das ist hier
funktioniert hier besonders das hat man
hier natürlich auch besonders hoch
gerüstet an dieser stelle wollen wir
einmal elmar brok verabschieden vielen
dank dass sie sich die zeit für uns
genommen haben um meine nächste frage
würde ich an philipp potthoff in lemberg
stellen philipp wir haben heute mit dem
man mit einem us-general gesprochen der
gesagt hat putins arroganz wird ihnen
seinen sieg kosten wie ist deine meinung
dazu
ja zuerst einmal gute nachrichten aus
lemberg es gibt gerade entwarnung
nachdem luftalarm und ich glaube der
us-general kann mit seiner feststellung
durchaus recht gehabt haben denn ich
glaube es gibt durchaus gerade einen
machtkampf im machtapparat emmel auf der
einen seite gute der offenbar mehr oder
weniger eigenmächtig diesen krieg
geschlossen hat und sich dabei auf
vollkommen falsche einschätzung berlins
also er verließ sich auf die
einschätzung seines geheimdienstes dass
du keine erstens nicht in der lage sich
zu wehren und zweitens die ukrainischen
bürger die russischen soldaten mit
blumen und freudentränen begrüßen werden
und stattdessen wurden sie mit
handgranaten und molotowcocktails
begrüßt und die ukrainische armee hat
sich als sehr kampf gewesen und diese
arroganz die so hoch gewesen dass er
dachte tatsächlich in zwei bis drei
tagen nach kehrt marschieren zu können
und eine sie gerade in der hauptstadt
der ukraine abzuhalten was hat
offensichtlich nicht funktioniert man
hatte auch keinen plan b oder 10 all
diese strategie wechseln die jetzt
ergründet werden sind glaube ich aus der
not heraus geboren du stehst du in
lemberg philipp und da schaut man auch
immer ein bisschen besorgt hoch nach
belarus von dort sollten große offensive
kommen wir wissen dass wladimir putin
versucht hat bei lukas schenkel dem
diktator in linz durchzusetzen dass auch
dessen truppen aktiv eingreifen und
nicht nur er nur sein territorium zur
verfügung stellt das ist ausgeblieben
gewissen von verhaftungen auch unter den
russischen generieren oder offizieren
die sich geweigert haben an diesem krieg
teilzunehmen wie groß ist wie groß ist
der ausfall für wladimir putin wenn
belarus da nicht mitspielt
ok das ist die frage an maxim
maximow
bilder russische armee ist die ich
sowieso nicht das ist eine politische
frage als eine militärische frage der
wille russische armee dringt nicht
darauf zu kämpfen und ich glaube nicht
dass man hier viel erwarten kann
hinsichtlich der unterstützung aber
russland möchte ich mich einsam hier
kämpfen
in dieser position und russland möchte
natürlich dass die anderen ländern die
zu dem militär bund gehören
belarus kasachstan und andere länder und
natürlich ist belarus der engste partner
und natürlich weil sie hier nicht
mitmachen und dass sie solange die grimm
dieses thema creme nicht anerkannt haben
und auch andere außenpolitischen
aktionen russlands nicht anerkennen dann
ist es natürlich ein deutliches zeichen
und natürlich hat lukas schenkel eine
wunderbare möglichkeit jetzt bekommen
vor einem jahr war lukas schenkel
wirklich der monster europas und jetzt
versucht man mit ihm zu einer einigung
zu bringen was kann man von ihm erwarten
jetzt
was muss dann lade ich mir putin jetzt
aus sicht der russen die er in der
mehrheit diesen krieg ja deutlich
deutlich befürworten was kann wladimir
putin als geringsten erfolg mit nach
hause bringen damit er die damit er die
anerkennung nicht verliert den rückhalt
ein mächtiges
wenn draußen sind und auch in europa
haben wir dieses körper kalender
unterstützt oder so etwas werden
unabhängig von der umgebung es wird für
sie nicht dass das richtige sein was
tatsächlich passierte sondern wie das
dargestellt
nach einem monat wird keinen richtigen
erinnern dass man versprochen hat kiew
ein zunehmender geburt der kunde kaufe
ich muss sie an dieser stelle einmal
unterbrechen wir müssen nämlich jetzt
einmal in die werbung gehen wir werden
natürlich den ganzen abend weiter über
diese neueste nachrichten aus china und
der ukraine berichten und sind dann
gleich wieder für sie da erst mal vielen
dank an diese gesprächsrunde und wie
gesagt wir bleiben vor ort und melden
uns dann gleich wieder